[Music]
a given 16 horsepower centrifugal pump
has an efficiency of 83% and produces 65
PSI of pressure head what is the flow
rate of water that it is able to
pump so let's start by looking in the
manual for something with the word pump
in
it you could also search by terms like
centrifugal or pump efficiency which
might get you there faster no matter
what you should end up in the pumps
section on page
335 of the
manual so we can see here under fluid
power equations there are two equations
given which we could use to solve this
problem they might look different at
first but are pretty much the same
equation with some of the terms in
different units depending on which
equation you're looking
[Music]
at for
example
row * G is actually gamma this might not
be in the manual but it's something to
remember from fluid mechanics
Additionally the power of the pump is
either given in
Horsepower or in pound foots per second
the second equation even provides the
conversion from one to the
other so let's lay out our units and see
if we have enough here to solve for flow
rate like the question asks
first we have our horsepower given as
16 this is the
pump Brak
power in either
BHP or you can convert
it
to foot pounds per
second
next we have our pressure head given as
PSI this is our H
term or we could convert
it to
feet finally we have our efficiency
which was given at 83%
and this is the value
new so let's take one of these two
equations and start plugging in our
terms given that 16 horsepower is
already given as the proper units here
I'm going to use the second one
so
HP equals Q which is what we're solving
for gamma which is 62
.4 pound per cubic foot of water and you
can find this in the reference manual on
page two if you need it but it's good to
have memorized and then finally our
pressure head which is in
PSI but we should convert it
to feet to be consistent with our other
terms here so the unit conversion page
of the reference manual shows
that
1T is equal
to
0.433
to psi of H2O and on the bottom we've
got
550 foot pound per
second times new which is
83% given as
0.83 so if we multiply these two things
over here here and isolate Q by dividing
this whole quantity we will be able to
get Q equaling
0.78 fet cubed per
second um and that's all it takes to
solve this problem in summary this
problem mostly requires you to do some
unit
conversions and know where some terms
are so that everything in the fluid
power equation cancels out it'll also
save you some time if you can recall the
density of water or at least know where
to find it on page two cuz otherwise you
won't be able to solve the problem and
that's it